bonjour curieuses et curieux aujourd'hui
je vais faire appel à vos plus mauvais
souvenir de vie en société
les mouvements de foule donc au choix
les gens qui poussent le matin pour
essayer de rentrer dans le métro
la sortie de votre concert électro
préféré ou la ruée vers la nouvelle
caisse de supermarché qui vient de wave
et bien sachez que tous ces phénomènes
ressemble à ça des chercheurs de la
région parisienne se sont intéressés à
la modélisation mathématique des
mouvements de foule
le principe de base est assez simple
imaginez que la foule se comporte comme
un ensemble de grains en mouvement un
peu comme ce qui se passe dans un
sablier avant de commencer il faut
établir un certain nombre de règles
si on représente les hommes par des
boules si on représente les individus
par des disques et qu'on étudie leur
position toutes les configurations ne
seront pas permises
les boules ou les disques ne pourront
prendre qu'un certain nombre de
trajectoires pour se ruer vers la sortie
pour modéliser mathématiquement une
foule
la première contrainte que les boules
doivent respecter est évidemment
l'interdiction de se recouvrir l'une
l'autre
les bulls peuvent entrer en contact ce
qui est représentée ici par des traits
mais elle ne se chevauchent pas non pas
de ça chez nous on ne se chevauchent pas
on suppose également que les personnes
connaissent les lieux chaque boule et
donc individuellement capable de
déterminer sa trajectoire optimale
c'est à dire le chemin le plus court
vers la sortie
en évitant les obstacles dans cette
simulation plus les boules sont rouges
plus elles sont comprimées ces
contraintes limitent donc les mouvements
à un certain nombre de possibilités que
l'on peu formalisés mathématiquement
[Musique]
on peut alors définir l'insatisfaction
de chaque individu comme la distance lui
restant à parcourir pour atteindre la
porte plus il est loin plus son
insatisfaction est grande et
l'évacuation de la foule ou consiste
donc à minimiser l'insatisfaction global
qui est la somme des insatisfactions de
chacun des individus
cet ensemble d'individus peut également
être décrit macroscopiquement c'est à
dire qu'on peut le considérer comme une
entité dont l'évolution est semblable à
celle d'un fluide
certaines situations donne des résultats
comparables que l'on utilise une
description microscopique ou
macroscopique de la foule
c'est le cas par exemple pour cette
modélisation d'un groupe de personnes
qui sort du métro pour se diriger vers
un escalator peut-être d'ailleurs que
c'est une situation désagréable que vous
avez déjà des cas cependant si l'on
regarde dans le détail certains effets
ne sont décrits que par une modélisation
microscopiques
c'est le cas notamment de l'effet que
les chercheurs ont appelé faster et
selon quel accent parfois lorsque toutes
les personnes poussent pour atteindre la
sortie on arrive à un blocage est ce qui
peut sembler paradoxal c'est que plus on
cherche à sortir rapidement plus cette
situation se produit
en gros plus on veut aller vite plus on
pousse et plus ça bloque
d'où le nom de faster is love her oui
parce que fast and furious était déjà
pris les mathématiciens ont alors
introduit une composante psychologique
dans le comportement des individus
la foule de biens sentimentale soit
l'idée est donc de forcer certaines bull
a arrêté de pousser pour libérer le
blocage sur cette image la foule est
bloqué
les flèches correspondent à la vitesse
souhaitée par chacune des boules si elle
était seule à ce stade les chercheurs
impose que la vitesse souhaitée d'une
boule diminue lorsqu'elle est bloqué
pendant un certain temps
cela revient à dire qu'un individu
arette 2 pouces et quand ça n'avance pas
c'est de la courtoisie
c'est donc la courtoisie qui permet de
débloquer la situation dans cette vidéo
de boules enfin les mathématiciens ont
retrouvé dans leur modèle un effet
surprenant et déjà observée est utilisé
en architecture la présence d'un
obstacle en amont de la sortie rang
l'évacuation plus rapide
[Musique]
voilà donc même avec une description
assez limitée du comportement humain
cette modélisation mathématique permet
de reproduire de nombreux phénomènes
observés lors des mouvements de foule y
compris certains effets paradoxaux sur
ce c'est la fin de l'épisode et j'en ai
la boule au ventre
je vous laisse admirer ce que serait la
sortie d'une salle d'exposition avec des
individus courtois et respectons à une
distance entre eux ici pas de full
contact
[Musique]
pas la foule qui nous traînent aux
entraînements n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner et allez faire un tour sur la
chaîne du cnrs où vous trouverez
d'autres contenus scientifiques plus
journalistique et documentaires abonnez
vous